come here hey he's come close but is
proving tough to catch for about 2
months locals just west of Parksville on
Vancouver Island have been told to be on
the lookout for a wolf dog the mixed
breed animal believed to be about 70
kilos has come close to traps set for
him but always walks off he knows where
the Trap is he knows the food but he
just doesn't like the food that we're
putting in like McDonald's cheeseburger
roast chicken he's either getting fed up
there or the rabbits are really good one
of the two come here
you come on because of his slippery
tactics he's been given the name WD40
it's believed he was kept as a pet but
dumped by his owner a Community member
called in Gary shade with fined and lost
Escape dogs Vancouver Island
conservation won't touch it Animal
Control won't touch it so he's kind of
in the middle so it's kind of up to the
private people to get it shade says the
animal has claimed this large area to
himself at least one dog has been
attacked and there have been some close
calls with humans he's followed a couple
of girls in a horse there last Friday
and then just went off in the bush
members of the public are being asked to
stay away from the area until the animal
is caught a trail cam is set up on this
live trap so shade can see when his
Target is nearby this going to be a slow
process know we got to get the right
food that he likes and he's got to get
hungry enough shade says a Local woman
with experience raising wolf dogs is
ready to give WD40 a home once he's
caught Alyssa TBO Global News